she's a mare will be here for this sure
I think they can reveal I think so
you guys are walking in to something
enormous all right what's up okay what's
going on breath we had a we were we had
an exploratory committee working during
the last segment trying to figure out
who was the guy that Jim was thinking
about that started with the expose and
then went to the Atlanta Braves are you
what he has baseball fans yes okay four
years the Montreal Expos were like the
farm system for the entire yeah because
nobody could they couldn't no they
couldn't afford to pay guys once they
got good and I had it in my head that
Fred McGriff played for them before he
went to Atlanta turns out I was wrong it
was Toronto so I'm like I was obsessed
I'm like somebody played for the Expos
and they went to the Braves and became a
huge star who is the Fred McGriff of the
Expos was the question I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I was thinking of Fred
McGriff Pedro I think was one but that's
not who I was thinking of Danny Martinez
Dennis Martinez playing for the
explosion the Braves but you were
thinking of Fred McGriff you were wrong
the whole hundred-percent Martinez
Dennis Martinez okay one of the more
team his brothers yeah I don't know why
I was obsessed with that night I was
just wrong don't worry I don't I have no
excuse at all the Travis brought in our
producer brought him a printout of all
the players to played for both the
Braves and the Expos and we analyzed it
during the break I put on my [ __ ] old
man
I realized as I was going down the list
I'm like why I'm halfway through I'm
like I don't know what the [ __ ] you have
to let go those little drive you nuts
they will yeah and I just there's so
many to remember I was wrong so much
it's too much off my chest
good yeah and if he didn't bring me that
printout the rest of the day I would
have been like those guys are idiots and
someone I thought Fred McGriff and
Travis was so confident he played for
Toronto [ __ ] what's going on vibrations
what was it like on your how thrilling I
should say was it on your last show with
the Pope yeah he's like oh my god it's
you two like you have no idea who we are
right all right if you're a year
probably like ten minutes away from
calling the cops on this but thank you
for being here do you enjoy him
legitimately or ironically like you
rebel because sometimes you don't want
facts you just want pure fury and rage
after yelling for no reason is that
beautiful New York thing of adding the
art of the yeah I like when he gets away
from sports and talk to other things
knows nothing about you're just like wow
I'm on my fifth hour of listening to
this show today yeah like you are in a
personal relationship with my friend
he's just talking to you all day of
quorum in your streaming and it's like
yo either his voice like hey sexy like
oh god oh what the [ __ ]
I never liked them because I hated the
theme song for Mike in the mad dog tryam
nothing can get by has there ever been
any Sports Talk intro song that's been
good know Sunday Night Football ones are
terrific what's the most recent one that
she just took a beating for - Carrie
Underwood song there was one that she's
getting somebody gettin killed for I
don't even like sports and I'm obsessed
with Mike Francesa just because of
everything around him around he's like
oh yo guys are lucky I came back from
retirement like it's a humiliating move
maybe the way he came back but he was
bragging about it pirate tour was like
three times longer than his retirement
was hey you know the samurai as Yankee
fans we're like we miss him cuz they
have we had the whole red sock Yankee
fight early in the beginning of yeah see
she's got the guts of a burglar he's a
loser and it's the funniest [ __ ] ever
was he came on the show and like you
know cameras are rolling all the time on
that show and he came out he was like
he's like yeah I had to do the show yeah
Bill Simmons good friend of mine these
guys haunting me to do the show he's
haunting he's calling me every day you
gotta do the show you guys do the show
you guys there's a haunted me just found
me I was like to go to you know wine to
brews waited to do is his bonus show for
his app unfortunately I I like many of
the Mike Francesa obsessed are not
subscribed
that's Eli's QB rating right now Wow
bombing that's he's straight yeah let me
ask you about for intensity because we
were theorizing this when you talk to
him in person yeah on the air off the
air whatever do you think that he thinks
of himself as the Pope in an ironic
sense or do you think that he thinks of
himself as the Pope like you know like
you know when grandpa grandpa's not do
too good and they have moments of
lucidity like he was he was a kind of
self-aware on in the interview he was
like the princess the kind everybody
yeah he has a little bit of
self-awareness but you know but don't
have a challenge in my facts I saw
Mickey Mantle once you have
grandfather's no oh yeah oh yeah your
grandfather's Mickey Mantle guess what
I blew Mickey Mantle in 68 your father's
no Mickey Mantle how do you guys handle
it when like you make it you make your
bones goofing on stuff huh and it's
never like mean it's just always like
light-hearted joking around yeah but you
get big enough mm-hmm that you're it's
your responsibility now to have it take
and joke about everything yeah and
people end up getting sensitive to the
point where like you get encounter
whether it's DJ envy or whoever that you
get encountered by people they're like
and you're looking at him like you're
taking what we say seriously DJ envy
like we made an ancillary part of a
morning show
that's Charlemont show and Angela Yee
doesn't
comedy show and not he said ancillary
it's over like he did the whole thing
and it was like a pulp of a CSUN and
blah blah blah he walked out on his own
show while they were on it because he
couldn't he was like oh we were out
there to promote our show and we had no
idea this was going to happen oh you
know I mean this is like the equivalent
of us coming up here and you being like
hey I heard you like to touch kids you
know Jesus ambushing us like hey what's
going on yeah right
you guys are doing the bodega boys live
yes this is opening up for us so bring
your weed I'm so stupid and gullible I
just said do you know I love it you
kidding me - I am so far I think 90% of
the jokes they've made you've gone
really got into a van when I was five
doesn't taste like puppy medicine
but did you get surprised when people
started taking serious because we you
know we've been on Twitter be on social
media always gonna be someone who does
not get a joke you say so your response
is it's more important your response to
them their response not getting it if
you're like go over a lot of times
you'll be like it was a joke bro and you
just put it out there and real crazy if
they're just like oh my god why would
you say it because then other people
come to them like bruh so joke they're
comedian Tom now if they do you know
anyway it's funny because it's like the
whole thing is like we are a cultural
commentary show we comment on pop
culture sports politics whatever
anything that's in the zeitgeist is a TV
Guide bio we talk about so like if
you're in there you're in there right
under me like so when Kanye does his
White House trip are you guys going like
what the [ __ ] why is now the time that
we're not ya know I think there's so
many things right now that happening
that we're like damn why our show ended
like the new cycle just spit up - yeah
crazy about so I'm just at home and I
love a clock like they tell you that
they were not gonna have you for the
last two months
vice lane you mean yeah did they did
they was it a friendly call with a
furious how do they let you know this is
just you're done it was just like
corporation I'm saying
shake hands goodbye you know don't take
any harmless from the kitchen but they
did let you do other day like other
shows before you knew in advance you
were coming off dating just late like on
radio you do your last show we had a
wonderful the last episode with my
princess my friends do we have champagne
three times plus it's a pre-taped two
radios live yeah that's the that's it
guys that's how they react in there like
alright uh we're gonna see you guys down
for a couple of days and then all the
sudden they're just prepping to bring
somebody else's where you find out in
the end like you do the morning show and
then that afternoon they switch formats
you're like what yeah morning sure
exactly met wait I thought we were
tomorrow am I supposed to be I'm doing
the gangster rap Drive
I don't understand yeah
I'm my name is not sway I'm gym floor
mat flips are the best you know I mean
you go in the morning you do your show
and then all the sudden they're playing
cartel beheading music after Billy is
great this is a lively video you watch
for a little too long and you just sit
in there like looking at your back with
like why would I do that yeah I finally
tapped out I can't do any more really I
watched from the other day and it almost
made me throw up
I was so upset I said no more I will not
go to so physically I was gonna vomit
and I had to walk around the apartment
he go that's the second time that's
happened to me I'm like I'll never do it
again ya know it's funny because like we
on a particular instance there was this
video of like one of those like like
asphalt steamer like smusher things with
a huge [ __ ] wheel and like a
steamroller roll yeah
Oh Steamroller there's a steamroller
that tips up and like the heavy part is
like in the air and the people like
workers are either trying to like
maneuver it down and this lady gets
under a cliff and it didn't
the forklift was lifting something and
that was too heavy so it lifted a back
this worker went and tried to pull it
down from the slips falls underneath the
forklift why would you why would you try
to pull it down from the back like
Wadley videos it should be caught
stupidity yeah why would you do also
what job I'm not I've never worked any
job where I'm risking life on them I'll
be like wow that forklift is up in the
air I'm watching this yeah that's like
the original before any of this stuff
was that popular like one of the first
things that I ever saw in liveleak was
like the videos of the guys that would
be on top of the Train yeah
they grab onto the wire smoke coming out
of him that was taping this so you
thought it was gonna go a different way
what do you do goes awry he just like oh
he died upload he got he fell in between
the train and the water and and the UH
the wall there was just no room and he
had spun around and spread around then
kicked out back onto the platform but
he's still intact so you know his legs
are probably broken but he lived through
it you almost never see that those guys
always get shot down yeah [ __ ]
hamburger means yeah yeah but this guy
lived for he just got lucky the right
angle and he flopped back up out of the
[ __ ] platform I don't know where I
don't think that was New York oh I just
keep thinking like to this dick get
crunched or his legs good in New York
you know 14th Street there's the is like
weird extender thing that comes out when
you're taking the shuttle across to the
times where shall I tell ya that it
comes out yeah so this guy like muscle
minotaurs you know listening to the
[ __ ] like I don't know the Beatles on
his ear pauses just like walking onto
the train bah bah bah falls into the gap
the thing comes out crushes him and then
like he's just he's alive and then the
people that you know EMS comes and
everything in Baba they get him out and
the guy can't like it's one of those
situations routes like
in a movie it's like if we move him
he'll die just let him say his final
goodbyes and all the the person that
it's all operated its automatic operated
the extenders there's no physical person
at the station all the time to turn it
off they had the Corso and turn off and
the person was that like 96th Street
location you know train the train system
is run on like pigeon wire and like
violin strings there you go down to any
minute there's nothing to do whatsoever
wow there's like a big control room how
the five Shane gets to the city like
alright I guess it's clear Ed Koch is in
a basement somewhere shoveling coal into
a furnace what is this Showtime show
start 2019 2019 like sometime between
nineteen if I have a break though isn't
it - like you guys get the holidays
office you know for kids I like to run
around with them and throw a ball and do
stuff like that you know I mean it's
good to have free time wake up no kids
up I just od to do right I'll play like
black ops 2 call the duty and like so
kids like go [ __ ] you I'm like I have a
TV show stuff like dick what was the
what was the move for you guys when you
realize like holy [ __ ] this is a big
deal Fat Joe was like yo you have to buy
a house in New Jersey yeah he literally
told me that he was like yo you're from
the Bronx you get money now you have to
buy a house in New Jersey trust me and
you have a house in New Jersey told me
this in like a cat like a beige sport
coat we went out to LA and on Pharrell
was he said to me very softly he was
like you're the truth in two years
you're gonna be bicoastal money like
that Pharrell he was like I just see it
for you and like now I'm just like damn
I'm sure you own this place here yeah
I'm in the process I'm still keep it up
keep it funky you know I'm saying yeah I
do
and anybody ever tried to like broaden
you guys like you know I know the bodega
thing worked in New York but a lot of
places don't know bodegas we don't them
up with something else
you have Network Busan - a long time ago
but they con their notes were constantly
like you guys are too - no it's not
gonna translate to a national level to
regional ya know cuz no one knows
anything about New York yeah why is that
building on the point on the top what is
that you know they'll rock like water
Perry is ignore the way you know he also
said that about the Pope he's like I you
know what I'm a New York guy so what but
to be fair to Mike Francesa
his role on a national level has not
been have you had any conversations
about whether or not you've got to
change things for Showtime Showtime is
like there's no censors we might make
actual live video you could do whatever
you want when they say something like
that that you're like oh really yeah
okay by fence cable though you should be
able to curse on it five times they gave
us five bucks yeah and we exhausted
those within the first episode [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the ones you did who is
America oh yeah we saw that I was going
okay good they have lawyers they got
lawyers now have you have you talked
about like with them how you maintain
your digital presence because obviously
their subscription network you guys have
oh yeah you know 100 percent
the fans can still get the podcast it's
gonna be super accessible like it's not
like that's amazing like yo sold out but
it's still gonna be the shows like the
material there's something you want to
see it's still there be super sir I mean
okay we are gonna sell out soon yeah
Brian's it's common just give me money
making money is selling the same people
make the mics on app we're gonna get
them doing cash for gold ads with Montel
yeah it really is a it's it's good like
nowadays that networks are starting to
figure out that when you have these
personalities that click with an
audience that you kind of have to adjust
the way content is put out you can't
just snatch them away like haha got the
hostage I know all the fans will pay for
it
know they'll rebelled I love these guys
but like I also like to eat ramen and
also if you're fans with a fanatical
they'll just like start bootlegging
yourself in and yeah cuz I've been that
you know like I you know it's like
taping your [ __ ] out of show that's
finally deleted as soon as they relist
[Laughter]
i'm we do anything that like is a
listener event or when it jim's comedy
shows or whatever we half the audience
as IQ oh man I love the show you know
I'm a YouTube listener but W and I'm
like that doesn't Britain tell us our
show is [ __ ] bill your [ __ ] mate Peter I
was like I've never put that much effort
into any relationship or anything no
you're doing that so this to a show my
god how do they do it cuz I've tried to
do that for Netflix because there's
certain things that are only on us
Netflix in Canada or whatever yeah and
it doesn't work you gotta get a VPN I
just wonder what you gotta like spoof
your IP address it looks like it's
coming from a region where the property
is allowed to play and like well the
time I did that and it caught it the
second time it did they whatever their
software is Netflix is not just doing it
to
that you can't they really don't want
you watching and if it has not been
legitimate they might be monitoring you
they probably are either wot monitor
everyone in the United States are just
stupid [ __ ] like a sixth sense I wanted
to watch what I was doing no no you hear
watch when I was outside the country and
the only thing that I could still watch
all the shows all the commercials went
away it was like I had the Premium Hulu
all of a sudden because all the
commercials were country coded in Hell's
Kitchen with no commercials every night
did you really watch the commercial when
he came home oh yeah when you watch the
legal NBA or NFL stream off already and
it's like some local programming in
Minnesota is that the commercials just
sitting there like what you guys
advertise hot dogs used to Jersey
commercials because it's like
commercials for the in-state pride of
Rutgers you can go to the University of
Maine I was like who wants to go to the
University of Maine do you like Jersey
compared to where you grew up I like
where I grew up better you're now mine
huh are you an Alpine no which is like
adjacent to Paterson so like if I want
to still be in the hood like I can just
turn through corners and still be in the
hood but like I like it for my kids
because it's like they have a yard they
have grass yeah you know what I mean
like they got a there's like a local
pool that's like you know you know
you're not gonna get a soul today and
like a lot of it's a it's like a it's a
cul-de-sac too so it's like they can go
out and like run in the street whereas
before like I lived on a Main Avenue and
like if my I was scared shitless
it's like a ball rolled off the sidewalk
into the street I'm like Mike is gonna
get killed by a [ __ ] uber it's gonna
be panicky to have a kid in the city
right you said there's one misstep in
between cars at the same time your kids
grow up sharp with it and like most kids
probably take it you see little kids in
New York like go to Times Square at
midnight you're gonna see like a
four-year-old walking along alone with a
MetroCard you're fine just come on come
from Hamilton
you know it's my cheat day so my trust
fund money so I have to go to see
Hamilton and I was watching I was
walking on down second Avenue and
there's like a little girl and one of
those little scooters she's my for yeah
and she was probably a half a block
ahead of her father and little brother
and he's on the phone talking to the kid
and a little girl goes around the corner
out of his sight and I'm watching this
I'm like how is this [ __ ] guy not
concerned it's crazy rich people rich
people all give a [ __ ] he didn't care
damn rich people give me [ __ ] like I'm
like I just started getting money so
like I give a [ __ ] about my kids so like
I'm worried about yeah rich people are
just like nanny nanny please to make my
child safe you know I mean like it's
somebody else's responsibility yeah
you're somebody else's responsibility
like oh like I got a nanny cuz my every
time I would come home my wife looked
like she had just survived like a brutal
attack supermarket like parking lot and
like I was just like alright we got four
kids it's one of you it's four against
one this zone defense is not working we
gotta get somebody in there so we got a
nanny but like most rich people just
getting we'll have one kid and like a
[ __ ] Portuguese water dog and get a
[ __ ] $1,000 a pair you know I mean
how much is it nanny is it expensive
it's kind of expensive is it more than
two grand a month no okay mine is not
how about for an au pair what you know
pairs anyone who's there all the time
those are like the hot ones that like
like Eastern European like whatever like
you know what's the funny with the nanny
that was a really messy yeah if you're a
woman I don't know
yeah my name is not honor or maybe the
wife maybe the wife thinks she's hotter
than a nanny and she has to learn the
hard way guess what even if you want the
nannies new the wife thinks she's LeBron
in the Lakers and then the nanny's the
Warriors like oh listen I'm dropping 30
is there ever any jealousy that you're
sitting there right you got four kids
you got an au pair
you got mortgage payment you got all
this stuff going on you just you know
you're hanging out in your place with
your video game
and you're splitting the money and it's
like his he's really got like four times
as much money as you cuz he's just
buying sneakers yeah yeah and you got to
spend it all on real lifestyle ya know
it's crazy and it's it's it's it's good
because I feel like it keeps me grounded
and I say it all the time I was like if
I didn't have four kids I'd have like
two Lamborghinis and I probably did it
all in commercials airhead in like a
leftover Heineken it's like Andy Andy
listen I stay away from sweet lady H I'm
fine nice to have no responsibilities
like other than your bills and your gig
right I have no one else we're just like
you know like no one loves you yeah
that's cool and you know it sucks let
you explain that lifestyle everybody
would look at you and be like that's the
life and no but like I have kids like
nobody would look at a person with kids
and go like yeah you know I figured it
out because with the other day that's
like I feel like dudes are like when you
know when you're cleaning your house and
like I'll sweep the floor and get winded
and like take a four-hour now he goes
must be nice I was like oh [ __ ] you guys
matter what time you're home I don't
even have to come home but three weeks I
have a cat it's another come home and a
cat looks I'll be like yo fam it's been
three weeks like
Amazon Prime have you been cats just
yelling at echo co-owner
just like puts in on my cat go to
voicemail
although you could probably try to use
that card to like no no I get it I know
you got kids I have a cat this on its
own its own automatic feeder I totally
and secretly just hates me and is
waiting for me to die so they can take
over the apartment yeah you're okay to
my house issues like oh wow you know
that's why you have a cat you know you
got to change its kid you got to change
the litter like every couple of days you
know it's time to change it when the cat
is standing on a pile of [ __ ] take out
the garbage is carefully pacing on top
that's real confidence though when like
somebody says that to you and you don't
think your first thought is not like oh
no I've been doing it wrong your first
thought is like